oh hello there Billy
welcome everyone to the Sarah Palin in
Billy Ray something's looking it get
away those little shoe fella
well T today's podcast is brought to you
by our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ of
course just like holy-moly
is off to the Lord and Savior she's
brought to you by we had Sarah my name
is Billy
hi Billy Ray so uh how are you today
miss ma'am I'm doing well I mean I am
just getting out there and running as
much as I can every single day and my
knees are starting to her a little bit
I'm a little bit old but you know I just
take it one day at a time
you just run through the snow or you go
around it no I run through the snow I
mean I live in Alaska so it's quite
difficult to just never run through the
snow there's some wolves of their finest
quite a rock yes when is Alaska gonna be
officially moved away in not part of
America I heard that was happening what
way did it already happen no you see
that's never going to happen cuz we're
part of the United States of America
didn't you run for something yes I ran
for the vice president but you said
you're still running like everyday why
are you running if you lost that's a
valid point ah but it's a different type
of running it's like I on my feet the
kind before was like a that's just what
you call it when you want to get elected
oh also figuratively figuratively yes
but now I'm literally running she's
literally running I lost a lot of weight
so that means that you overweight when
you were figuratively running no I was
just regular weep and I am definitely
underway
okay that's good so for today's podcast
I thought could be really fun if Billy
and I interviewed each other yeah I
think that would be a stupid be a good
idea I got some good things to say and
I'm talented so this is that that's
right Billy that's right so would you
like to ask the first question or would
you like me to ask the first quake I'm
just so excited I think this is gonna be
so much fun Billy I'm already having a
good time let me ask you do you prefer
being called Billy Ray or Billy mr.
Billy Ray Cyrus no that's my daughter's
name
so never Billy Ray Cyrus just just Billy
no mr. Billy Ray mr. Billy Ray yeah Oh
Billy all right I just wanted to check
out a respect
I appreciate it Sarah Sarah Sarah Sarah
within each you say it a little odd no
it's just an accent but I speak the same
way that you do where you also have an
accent oh I thought I was normal and
everyone else had an accent so you have
a you have a normal voice and I have an
accent too you in your mind yeah in my
mind you do you have quite an accent um
you said you were from Hawaii no Alaska
Oh Oh but they're close I got a question
for you Oh in the ocean sort of I mean
parts of Alaska at night you can see
Russia yeah so yeah I guess yeah do you
see the the lights at night out there
yeah you do there's lots of lights it's
beautiful you see all the stars and the
moon and Jesus sometimes we what there's
a aurora borealis do you know what that
is no what do you what is Bala it's like
a fantastic show I'd like green and blue
lights in the sky and I swear if you're
sitting down or kneeling during the
prayers during the aurora borealis you
can just hear the voice of God are you
sure that's not like like my voice cuz I
called you a couple of times and left a
voicemail on your answering machine and
that might have been me well it could
have been I mean I don't
check my voicemails that much oh I just
got a new answering machine what does it
say well whatever anyone calls me they
can record their voice and it's like
they're talking to me except I'm
ignoring them oh yeah so I have a
question for you Sarah do you have a
daughter and can she be friends with my
daughter I do have a couple of daughters
actually you probably have heard of
Bristol Palin she's very famous she was
on Dancing with the Stars and uh yeah
Dancing with the Stars
so that's it Sarah Palin's Alaska she's
very famous I mean I know that your
daughter Miley is very famous as well
but Bristol was famous first so I think
that makes her more famous well that's
debatable first of all I would love to
hear your your thoughts oh so we're
gonna have a debate no it doesn't need
to be a dick because you are in I mean I
think that's questionable I think that I
won my part of the debate so that's
really all that matters to me well it
also matters if America thinks you won
and I don't think they thought that well
I mean Jesus knows that I won so okay
well at least you have someone on your
team that's good Jesus is always on my
team can he be on my team - he's on
everyone's team doesn't he how does he
win every every game then because if
he's on everyone's team he has to lose -
Wow that's true because he just needs to
decide whoever is you know worthy of
winning that day that's who wins that
sounds good
I'll go with that okay so that so he's
on my daughter's team cuz she's winning
a lot we're on a bangers to it weren't
stopped here now on their way and have
you heard a music it's good
ah you know Billy Ray I'm sorry mr.
Billy Ray you can call me Billy well you
can call me Billy okay
that's funny because before you said you
wanted to be called mr. Billy Ray so
which one should I call yeah I guess it
doesn't matter but I changed my mind
because I'm feeling a connection I feel
close I don't want to be so formal that
makes me feel very good don't flatter
yourself too much now okay uh well you
know to be honest with you Billy I try
not to listen to a whole lot of Miley's
music because I just feel like it's
inspired by the devil whoa oh well
that's it that's incredibly offensive
sorry I mean I don't I don't want to
offend you but it just you know well she
tries her best and she's appropriate and
it's clean and PG as in every sense of
the letters so what about her music is
the devil just all the gyrating and that
drag smoke well I got a question for you
she wears basically just her underwear
all the time and that's what Jesus was
so what was a difference you know Billy
another to see that that's actually an
incredibly valid point so I would like
to give you credit for that Thanks
is it redeemable at Dave & Buster's or
is it just a figurative low credit it's
it's just like God Sarah and Billy are
having a conversation and you get a make
believe Jesus star for making a good
okay do you uh do you by any chance have
a question to follow up with me oh I do
Billy I have a list of questions I'm
also preparing a parade to success my
first question for you Billy is that
what were your thoughts when Miley
transitioned into a drug taking Satan
worshiper well for me as you know she
was very very sweet she was on the
Disney Channel and then all of a sudden
she's just you know praising see in well
for me it didn't happen it didn't happen
overnight it was a little bit of a
drawn-out process
um and then one day she's that I guess I
mean her musics really good I go to
sleep to it and wake up to it well I
feel like it was kind of very quick she
just all of a sudden was I thought you
said you never heard her music because
it was the devil so how are you being
able to categorize it out no I have
heard Miley's music so I called you a
lion now no I said I try not to listen
to it because it doesn't align with me
personally okay so to answer your
question what why did that happen or
when did it happen when oh it happened
when when that I was I was with Miley
and we were about to watch her on the
Disney Channel because she was good on
it she is a good actor and oh you your
commercial came on and she said daddy
what's that and I said don't look but
it's too late she was dumb now are you
calling me dumb and after Miley Cyrus
just makes music about popping pills and
just doing everything bad that the Bible
explicitly tells you you cannot do this
and get into heaven and you're calling
me stupid oh no I didn't call you I'm
just saying that you were the sole
reason she became the way that she is in
every bad sense of her character I
understand but okay my original question
was what were your thoughts as a father
oh well I was really really drunk but I
mean it was okay though because I woke
up the next day and I still had a roof
over my head because my daughter paid
for it and then we went on tour so I
forget what well is that is that the end
of you question because I feel like I
can answer that more than once and
you're not really taking my head so that
was the end of my question okay well
that's good because I got maybe a
question of to you yes let's move on to
the next question Billy oh how long had
was the longest time you've ever gone
without buying my album
ah you know I think that I did buy your
Achy Breaky Heart album what was the
name of that album I forget yeah I think
everyone did what well it's well you've
gone off topic now I wanted to know how
long it's been the longest streak you
could ever go without listening to my
godly voice I think maybe 30 or 40 years
that's not bad
some people have said infinity years
which made me feel bad but at the same
time I still I'm doing I'm doing well
there's like three record store is still
open in the US and my my album is in
none of them which I'm trying to fix but
the bottom line is I'm doing what I love
every day and I record all the time and
I'm doing podcasts like this with people
so that's really great Billy I'm I'm
very happy for you
Thanks I basically live vicariously
through my daughter who doesn't even
really live because she's so high all of
the time yeah I know it must be a little
bit difficult for you on the inside to
see your daughter out there doing so
great and you know that it just wasn't
in the stars for you well I guess that
makes both of us loses then would you
like me to ask you a question now man
yeah well I'm in the mood to answer
something before that you can shoot
don't shoot me with your gun because I
know you Alaskans carried him around
like that that's uncomfortable just in
case you're wanting to get a little you
know more leaderly over there why do you
know how does that mean okay where's
Marley I'm scared what do you pray for
at night
oh well basically I I just pray for my
hair to stay good that's important yeah
well thanks this is the first time I've
wanted naturally on camera two other
times it's been assisted by other hair
but that's one thing
pray for my hair that's a big step I
pray for my daughter because she's so
troubled ever since she was pretty much
by her sailing experience and then and
then I also pray that I could find my
leather band it was on my wrist one time
and then I lost it forever so if you
found it you could just mail it 234
Billy Lane I'll be there just post it
put a stick on it and give it to some
morning I'm so sorry to hear that it
will find his way to Daddy
but back to you're here I'm very very
impressed that you would admit that to
us that's that's a big step I'm happy
for you oh thanks hmm you look wonderful
oh well thank you Sarah hmm that's what
my daughter says to me too which makes
me feel good after her inappropriately
compliment her too but that's between us
can I ask you a question now yes
are you uh so would you call yourself a
politician or just some lady who dresses
all proper I'm sorry what was the last
and on that question are you uh just do
you do you dress proper is that all you
do hmm no I mean if you notice right now
I'm wearing my casual gear because I'm
down to earth I mean many people in
their mind they think that I'm just this
glamorous celebrity but I'm really just
a normal girl at heart I always have
been I can almost bet everything I've
ever owned on the fact that nobody
thinks you're glamorous or celebrity ah
I think that there's many many many
people that would disagree
especially all of the designers that
dress me on a daily basis but ah what
was the question do I am ia politician
or do I just dress proper okay so the
second half of that question no I just I
dress however I
is appropriate for the moment you know I
just like to live my life in the moment
and then ah yes I am a politician which
is how I got to the White House with you
not in a White House right now you're in
Alaska that's where we are right now
right was just like a hair away are you
just so close oh excuse me I thought you
said a second ago that you were in the
White House but was that just a figment
of your imagination telling yourself
that you'd won when you lost I think
sometimes it's okay to feel to try and
to feel which is what I did but there's
no reason for me to come in the future
and you know maybe you don't bring your
guns to podcast running for president in
the future
Oh president of what I do United States
of America of podcasts you'd be a good
president that I'm not sure that there
is a president well there is it now but
there will be when Miss Sarah Palin puts
on her grown-up pants and says I want
this position I was not good enough for
any other position they basically said I
suck all over America but I could do
this and then you do it and then maybe
you can meet my daughter Miley she might
autograph like a napkin well that's very
very sweet of you who Billy you're
welcome I've been called selfless before
but I've also been called very very
selfish and drunk are you drunk right
now I don't know I don't know how to
tell anymore there's little wolves
running manly right I feel like that
seems really sad from the inside
are you sad on the inside no just on the
outside I'm drunk on the inside so I
don't know what that is
all right how would you like me to ask
you a question in the form of English
with your mouth are you ever going to
get back into singing well as the matter
of fact I did just interview yesterday
for a janitorial
lost the interview because I threatened
the the lady who was being downright
rude when she said she didn't know who
my daughter was so I take those things
not so kindly and I may or may not have
killed her or something but I'm not
going to be a janitor in the state of
Illinois anymore but what was your
question there singing yes oh well it's
been hard because mooching off your
daughter really takes a lot of energy
and also I have an Instagram and I'm
like 70 so that's that's taken up a lot
of my time so probably never unless
unless unless you become the president
of pop cast and and I can sing whenever
I want and you get me record deals and
and basically work for me okay if you
want that job you give you be OK at it I
mean I am good at every job replaceable
but good I'm definitely a hard worker
and I'm certainly a maverick what what
the hell does I mean I'm maverick yeah
can you explain that to those you go
against the green and you just go out
there and do it yourself like a real
maverick I mean that was my entire
gimmick when I was running for the vice
president the united states that were
Mavericks I hate to bring it back to the
fact that you lost horribly but why
would you bring it back to something
that you had already lost from maverick
didn't work stop it
I mean I'm still the same election for
you standing in front of a country just
asking them to let her be the vice
president I have a question for you now
since you were just kind of rambling
okay
when I wake up I sometimes forget why I
was ever popular and I would I was I was
hoping that maybe every single morning
in my life you could call me and remind
me why I'm popular because you know more
than anyone because we are now pop cast
partners and also my question is why
does that happen
you every morning also ah well to answer
the first part of your question I see
you've been asking a lot of two-part
questions uh no Billy I cannot call you
every single morning to remind you why
you're popular pay you you don't have a
job right I don't think that you're very
popular uh and I'm still popular so I
just don't agree with the second half of
that question so I think I'm just gonna
skip it oh so so we just call ourselves
popular and then we're popular is that
worse because I'm pretty sure popularity
is based on everyone's opinion but your
owns so based on the fact that I have
like 300 Twitter people that say I'm
fake and not really Billy Ray and I'm
just a kid running the account I I'd say
I'm pretty popular kids know me okay
where's Miley have you seen her she said
she was gonna be walking around no I
have not seen Miley X with a black man
what okay why don't you you approve of
that define American for me are you a
true American I am American what but
what's what's an American to you you
know because for me like an American is
someone that loves our country that
carries guns and protects their home and
their family they're a breadwinner you
know well for me America is based on the
freedom of someone who wants to go out
and they want to buy themselves a new
technology phone and then have it
completely spied on forever because
that's freedom and when our forefathers
wrote that piece of paper whatever it
was called they remembered that this was
gonna happen because they were basically
scientists that could you know that
could tell so that's true no I just
wanted to say that but a beer a little
bandana maybe with some stars and
stripes on it and
a really hot daughter that's America
okay sounds a firework cuz I said
America again so are you are you a
Democrat or a Republican well well I'm
independent because I'm currently
forming my own party what would that be
well I can't tell you okay I could tell
you it's called Miley so you want Miley
to be its own political party I'm sorry
Billy but that just sounds a little bit
ridiculous well she basically runs the
whole world right now anyway so might as
well make it official you know I feel
like you could me that arguably would it
be true that all men are under the age
of 18 I mean when we're speaking about
voting
Miley can't be the boss of adults when
she's not an adult herself Miley is like
20 20 at least 22 so she's definitely an
adult according to America okay but you
can't be a president unless you're in
your mid-thirties well when Miley gets
elected she's going to change that rule
that says anyone can be elected as long
as her name is Miley Cyrus which is why
I want to find her because we got a
campaign meeting in like in like did you
do well in the last election
not in America I went to Kazakhstan but
they don't have votes I don't know how I
ended up there that's why I wanted to
ask you to call me remind me how I was
popular okay and maybe to also make sure
that you're safe and not in Kazakhstan
yeah it was no it was not fun I was
drunk poppy okay okay did you have a
question for me yeah I just got a look
at my computer the hair in my pants
matches your hair does that mean you my
cousin Gilly relleno this is the hair
color called brunette so just because we
have the same hair color certainly
doesn't mean that we're
related but it does mean that we're both
brunettes and humans
oh and since we're related now will you
go out with me tonight Miley's the Miley
won't know about it you know Billy Ray I
would love to go out with you anytime
right I'll meet you there
as your family member okay so so yeah
yeah okay all right I'm going on a date
with cousin Sarah tonight she's Sarah
Palin my cousin because we've got the
same hair color sort of but that's an
honor for you to have me as your date
okay I have a lot of kids is that okay I
know you have a lot of kids too you have
what like six kids no I don't think I
wanna what well people tell me that I
have more than one but Miley is one and
then yeah I mean I don't really care why
don't we talk about something a little
bit topic hall for fun okay what did you
think about the Kim Kardashian the
hashtag break the Internet with the this
champagne and her bum and the spewing it
over her head what did you think about
that well I think what she did in terms
of her publicist releasing that hashtag
with that dumbass [ __ ] photo is
basically equivalent with someone giving
themselves their own nickname it just
doesn't work if you're gonna break the
internet because you're that special
you're gonna just break it you don't
need to go tell people you can't break
it and if you don't you don't you don't
mean to be called by a real name cuz
you're too badass you need a nickname
other people are gonna tell you that you
need that nickname
you don't tell yourself you don't say
how I'm nicknamed dis no no no one came
up to Anderson Silva and says you know
you should make your own nickname no
they said you are a spider sir that's
what happened I would have to agree with
your ability an Internet isn't broken so
she clearly is a liar she probably got
like a thousand lawsuits lawsuits on
their hands yeah probably I mean I would
personally like to sue her because I
didn't ask to see her breasts and vagina
I didn't I just I went onto Twitter and
I felt that my eyes pileated yeah I was
I was violated what's not that time what
was that is this an experience that
you'd like to explain oh I see as you as
you could tell just now I almost cried
about it because I said Merrick oh
thanks Eddy have topic for you I'm sorry
you didn't deserve that and it wasn't
your fault okay have you seen any good
movies lately I heard aunt Estella it's
pretty good I think it's about some
people who leave earth because Sarah
Palin lives on it
no you know I haven't seen interstellar
and it's certainly not about me because
my lawyers then everyone would have told
me you know Sarah they're making this
movie about Joe and if they were I would
have asked for a date Jake so it's
definitely not the premise of the movie
all right if I start when you say that
you know I didn't see it belly oh I want
to see it I would also like to see it
maybe we could do that after dinner you
know that sounds lovely okay
what why don't we talk about ah oh Jesus
okay Oh
again you mean I mean you're a man of
faith aren't you what I'm a minify man
of faith what's that last word you say
it really wild faith yeah I'm whatever
faith ladies praising God and Allah
praise God yeah I mean you're southern
yeah I was from somewhere down there
hence the hair in the filet no Florida
well well tell me about your
relationship with Jesus Christ
well it's give and take a guess
sometimes he he's like hey Billy don't
get so drunk but then I get drunk and
then I yell at him and then I yell at
Miley because she doesn't let me be in
her videos anymore
what do you say to Jesus when you're
drunk and angry how could you ever yell
at Jesus oh I see
I say why is no one buying my album I
worked it for like three minutes on it
and then uh and then uh no one bought it
but it's not for sale so I forgive Jesus
it sounds frustrating well uh do you
later
do you snapchat Jesus I heard he's
pretty good at that NoHo I don't have a
snapchat well you got over there that
phone it looks like it could have one no
I don't have okay I could probably
install it for you I could do it on our
date tonight so you can only snapchat me
in Jesus we can have like a three-way
snapchat I would be okay with that as
long as there's no nudity and we're on
the same page Jesus is basically naked
so okay okay
well how's how's uh you know back home
it's getting quite chilly lately in this
fall winter months how do you live with
this all year well you just put on a
coat and you go outside and you just
deal with yeah I mean there's plenty of
things to eat you can kill the moose and
that the fiesh there's plenty of salmon
ah you know if it's not really legal but
if you see a bear you can kill it and
then you just you'll you stack up in
your house you build a fire and go
skiing it's totally fine and normal no
um sorry I just um I was a little scared
when you said you could kill it yeah we
kill a lot of animals in Alaska wouldn't
you think that if you're gonna be
running for president you may not want
to be saying that that's the American
Way Billy we kill our food oh okay well
where do you think that your food comes
from
well I only drink alcohol I've never
eaten food ever I don't even know how
I'm alive that's really dangerous well
you know you get used to it so it's fine
at least I'm not murder and
okay I disagree so when we go out for
that drink tonight could I also have
some some of your drink I mean you can
have some of mine okay I want my mousse
within reason I mean you don't go being
a lash you know Gladney is a sin oh so
is murder murder is a sin it's not
murder we we do it so that we have food
to eat
that's true that's true humans divorce
that's 3/4 of you drink to God's will
who are asked to kill our own food yeah
okay so I could just order us like three
shots and you can have one of them just
like I said it'll be another white light
wheat so okay fine so how about you just
bring like a water bottle and I'll just
drink all what we order okay I'm gonna
bring my daughter too
she should be around waiting but you
like her I think you'll have a lot in
common because she basically aligns with
everything you believe in
I don't think that that's true but
you're more than welcome to bring your
daughter oh I'm not talking about Molly
her name is Cyrus Cyrus
your daughter's name is Cyrus you have a
daughter named Cyrus Cyrus is she a
cyclops or something that's the most
ridiculous news not just Cyrus Cyrus
it's Cyrus Ray Cyrus Cyrus reign
staggering were you drunk when you need
your chat you know what yes miss Alice
Rock I was you're drunk
I was very very drunk you know I just I
get so worried about you because I mean
with all this drinking like the Lord
doesn't like that yeah I just cared of
going to hell um no I was under the
impression that that's why I was now so
Billy no you know how now
No why are you talking like that it's
very obnoxious just having a
conversation you don't do that noise
alright well you know now I feel a
little insulted if you're gonna make fun
of the way that I speak then I can make
fun of the way that you speak do it I
think that you sound saw like you don't
even know it what you're talking you're
making more fun of yourself when you're
trying to make fun Wow can you you mean
your kid Cyrus or Ray Cyrus that's what
you sound like you know that right it's
not how I some of those are just the
things I was saying you made no effort
to replicate my voice whatsoever I did I
haven't care about America were watching
I did a pretty good impression so what
country are you gonna lose an election
in next you know I'm an American I will
always be an American so it would be
America can and I will keep running and
I won't stop no matter what the nice
ears like you have to say the what nay
sayers oh the the Sears is a store that
sells what just there so the people out
there like you that like to tell me that
I can't do something and I can I can't
do anything that I set my mind to
okay I believe you I'm like your belly
you can't even make music that's your
only job I'm pretty sure I got really
famous on the music I made some a couple
of idiots bought it and then they were
like hey look at this guy he's got a
mullet and he can kind of sing in his
daughter's heart so that's what happened
I don't argue with any of those cuz
that's all valid points why don't we
move on to another question okay how
long is pop casco however long you went
well so there's like there's no rules oh
okay well that's good let's let's play a
game or something like do you want to
have some fun I think we should laughs
okay oh but you're hot oh well I thank
you I appreciate that
what are we laughing about
ah why don't we think of some jokes to
tell each other ok what did Jesus say
when he crossed the road what Jesus I
don't I don't get why that's funny
what what's your joke okay um what do
you call a fish with no eyes
what if Shh well like you made me
believe it was a real fish with no
eyeballs but then it turned out it was
just I and a lot of fish that's right
it's clever isn't it I know it fooled me
the first time to fool me only you can
have that you can keep it how can I keep
a joke I don't even know where to put it
that was done right now in the future
you can even reuse it again and again oh
okay so is it my turn to come over to
joke now yeah I don't have any jokes
so can I just talk about my life sure
okay one time I was uh I was hanging out
and Miley came to me and she was like
hey can I get twenty dollars and I was
like no he's that yet yeah what did she
want the twenty dollars for uh I don't
know
she was gonna eat drugs off of someone's
butt she was gonna pay to do it that's
horrible I know she's at least easy to
get pay if she's gonna do this stuff I
pay her when she doesn't you know I
would agree with you there I mean if
you're going to [ __ ] out your body you
might as well be getting paid for it
right
I mean prostitution is a sin but it is
the oldest profession known
right would you ever consider
prostitution no okay no but like really
like you you probably do it right no no
like like like say there was like aliens
rat and there was no government anymore
and no one even knew about you just like
they don't now and you had no chance
ever again and become an elected and it
was free for all and you can either
prostitute and [ __ ] the aliens for alien
money or you could die no what if Jesus
paid you to [ __ ] him no not unless you
were married okay what if Jesus proposed
to you you got married and eloped to Las
Vegas and then you had to have sex with
him in the pool of a hotel well yeah I
mean as long as were married that he
paid you for it and then it wasn't Jesus
that's deceiving and wrong I mean Isis
make the real me I was having sex the
real Lord would forgive me if I truly
believed in the bottom of my heart that
the man that I was we at was Jesus
Christ what if that is him know it's him
how can he not believe it if it's him
being the man you're not Jesus Christ
well that is very very debatable I don't
know well I'd say that this was a very
spectacular this is a fun pop cast can I
do it again with you
of course you can billy-ray I'll give
you guys an update on how our date goes
tonight I really don't I don't want this
snapchat it's a Monday night so I mean
it could just it could go one of two
ways it could go good or it could go
like a date on a Monday night
I just came can we like can we speak
privately about that about the snapchat
I really don't want
I don't want this tap job okay so we'll
just go for drinks and movie just and
snapchat for dessert no well you guys
can watch this podcast every week um
normally it's not us but who knows I
mean we may come back but you can you
can follow us around the street just
don't come that close you know and you
could follow us on yeah we're a little
old school if you follow us on Twitter
will find you and follow you back in in
person yeah we'll follow you just don't
follow us like too close because I might
I might just like start freaking out and
I do have guns yeah so don't touch me
don't touch me you're allowed to I'm
allowed get your hands off of her now
with your eyes your eyeballs are touch
okay well I guess if you have a mouse or
something like that you can click on the
left to watch last week's podcast and
then if you click on the right you can
watch the random ass [ __ ] I don't know
what it is I don't seem right though no
thanks for watching
yes this is a been so wonderful thank
you so much for watching and Billy Ray
you have been such a pleasure and I
can't wait to do it with you again oh me
too
I'm not like that baby - what are you -
I'm not a Q break a date tonight
goodbye everyone and go buy America
don't forget I will be running for
president so as soon as they raise
enough money I vote for that ass bye
everyone